اذا مشاهدينا الكرام كما ذكرنا بعد ساعات
قليله سندخل الاسبوع الرابع من القتال
المتواصل بين طرفي هذا الصراع الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع في البلاد في
السودان عموما ولكن الخرطوم كانت مسرح
العمليات خلال الساعات القليله الماضيه مع
تحليق مكثف للطيران في سماء الخرطوم
بمدنها الثلاث طبعا نعرف جميعا بان مدينه
الخرطوم تقع في الوسط في وسط البلاد كما
نشاهد على الخريطه وهذه صوره اقرب للخرطوم
بمدنها الثلاث الخرطوم بحري وام درمان
والخرطوم هذا هو النهر النيل الذي النهر
النيل الازرق الذي ياتي من الجنوب من
اثيوبيا ويقسم
العاصمه الخرطوم وهذا نهر النيل الابيض
كما نشاهد يشكلان مع بعض نهر النيل
العمليات العسكريه اليوم بدرجه اساسيه
تركزت في هذه الدائره محيط او النقاط
التقارب بين الخرطوم بحري ومدينه الخرطوم
وام درمان التي تربط بينها الاطراف الثلاث
تربط بينها عده جسور اذا ما اقتربنا اكثر
الى هذه الخريطه فنحن نتحدث عن القصر
الجمهوري الذي يشهد عمليات عسكريه مكثفه
خلال الساعات القليله الماضيه مع التمركز
لقوات الدعم السريع في محيط القصر
الجمهوري الامر الذي يؤدي الى هجمات من
قوات الجيش بالطيران وبالتالي انفجارات
وهذه اعمده الدخان التي كنا نشاهدها خلال
الساعات القليله الماضيه في محيط القصر
الجمهوري خلال عمليات الاشتباكات طبعا هذا
الامر لا يعني تمركز كل طرف في جهه معينه
مع ان قوات الدعم السريع تتمركز او
تتوزع بين الاحياء في مدينه الخرطوم هذا
ما يحول الامر ويحول المعارك الى ما يشبه
به معارك شوارع في هذه المناطق مع اتهامات
الجيش
[موسيقى]
القياده البلاد او القصر الجمهوري في هذه
النقطه يقع قصر الجمهوري وفي هذه النقاط
الشماليه كانت هناك اليوم عده انفجارات
لان قوات الجيش كما تقول قوات الدعم
السريع هاجمت بالطيران مقرات لقوات الدعم
السريع في هذه المنطقه منطقه خرطوم بحري
وتحديدا هلت حمد في هذه المنطقه
الغربيه من مدينه الخرطوم بحري كما نشاهد
في الشاشه هذه حلت حمد ويقع فيها معسكران
لقوات الدعم السريع معسكر في هذه المنطقه
الجنوبيه ومعسكر هنا عند كوبري شمبات كما
يقال له قبه هنا معسكران لقوات الدعم
السريع تعرضا اليوم لقصف من الطيران طيران
الجيش السوداني الذي يقول بانه يستهدف او
يلاحق من يصفهم بالمتمردين في هذه النقاط
اشير سريعا الى هذه
الجسور المهمه التي تربط بين الخرطوم بحري
والخرطوم هذه ثلاثه جسور مهمه هذه المسافه
التي نتحدث عنها نتحدث عن حوالي ثلاث مئه
متر الى 400 متر فقط التي تفصل بين
الخرطوم بحري والخرطوم وبالتالي العمليات
العسكريه يحاول كل طرف من الطرفين التقدم
باتجاه النقطه او الضفه الاخرى يحاول
الجيش السوداني التقدم باتجاه المناطق
الشماليه وحيث خرطوم بحري ويحاول الجيش او
تحاول الدعم السريع التقدم باتجاه المناطق
الجنوبيه طبعا عمليات الكر والفر بين
الجانبين مستمر هذه العمليات العسكريه كما
ذكر مراسلون قبل قليل ادت الى تفاقم
الازمه الانسانيه في البلاد في احد برز
اشكال هذه الازمه موضوع اللاجئين حيث قالت
المفاوضه اللاجئين الى ان هناك احتمالا
لمغادره اكثر من 860 الف سوداني للبلاد
خلال اذا ما استمرت المعارك خلال الفتره
القادمه وان بالفعل اكثر من 100 الف
سوداني غادروا البلاد حتى هذه اللحظه وعن
ونحن على مشارف دخول الاسبوع الرابع ولا
يبدو في الافق وقفا دائما لاطلاق النار
تكون هذه المعاناه معاناه اللاجئين احدى
ابرز الازمات التي خلفتها هذه المع